tonight President Trump turns up the
heat on North Korea adding economic
pressure on top of his firing military
threats he widen US sanctions today in
an effort to further constrict the
defiant regimes trade with the outside
world today I'm announcing a new
executive order I just signed that
significantly expands our authorities to
target individuals companies financial
institutions that finance and facilitate
trade with North Korea China their
central bank has told their other banks
that's a massive banking system to
immediately stop doing business with
North Korea so will it work doesn't
sound like the North's taking mr.
Trump's warnings very seriously here's
its foreign minister if they thought
they could scare us with the sound of a
dog barking that is a silly dream kim
jeong-hoon also chiming in according to
state news the mad dictator said today
president Trump is deranged and will pay
dearly for his threats so there's just a
lot of bluster there possibly Jessie but
one thing that we did find out today is
that after the president Trump made
those announcements you did have China
tell its the Bank of China
no more dealings with North Korea you
also had South Korea Japan even Russia
Australia all saying that the north has
got to stop so it could be that kim
jeong-hoon feels even more isolated than
he was that day for rocket man
I'll tell you that much Kaka man is
rocket man is I think a little bit
nervous as point so these two things the
executive order sanctions through Trump
and then the Chinese Bank action that's
a really powerful one-two punch the
significance of the Chinese action is
twofold one you have I think a huge
diplomatic victory for the president it
shows that is tough rhetoric by kind of
heightening the the level of rhetoric is
actually scaring some people into taking
action and it also shows that the
Chinese are willing to take a loss in
order to curtail their neighbors
behavior so we still have more cards to
play though you can still do ship
inspections you can still do a
full fuel ban you can still slap travel
bans on the rocket man I don't know
where he's going he could do financial
sanctions against them
wine and cheese import restrictions that
would really turn the screws to him but
the key point is is that the Democrats
taking shots at the president for this
dark and dangerous UN speech look
foolish because our Asian partners the
Japanese and the South Koreans came out
today they said that the UN speech was
strong and effective so I think now it's
time for America to speak with one voice
when it comes to North Korea yeah
California is in the crosshairs it
doesn't make any sense to talk the time
for talk is over and I looked at opinion
poll today 58% of Americans believe that
if economic sanctions do not work they
will support military action but a
majority of Americans also believe that
the North Koreans are bluffing so
there's still a little runway left I
can't get over that guy called our
president a dotard what is a dotard well
apparently it's someone who is elderly
and someone who was feeble of mine no
dear you Soros over there nice
preparation well I was sure that first
of all I think I know American us
English pretty well yeah I never heard
dotard I thought it was like a play on
words that he didn't understand but
actually it's a word getting lost in
translation
the other thing Kimberley is that when
kim jeong-hoon says that you know this
is just a dog that's barking the truth
is the dog also can bite if it has to
let's take a listen to a char McMaster
and get your thoughts on it what would
be the definition of being forced to
defend ourselves attacks on on us or our
allies so what does an actual attack of
course of course
and I'm curious about that because what
are we going to define as an attack and
on an on us or on an ally right so that
has to be something that needs to be
delineated because it's a very good
question because it could be far more
encompassing and is it something that
they're gonna put down and writing be
specific about ahead of time to kind of
set a bright-line rule I don't want to
say a redline and then determine or they
going to determine after and say in fact
this is someone that we
consider in this particular scenario to
be an ally of the United States one
would assume South Korea and give him
the presence of US troops there as well
in the military that's obviously
something that we would react you know
very swiftly to and with firing Furies
the president has stated but I really
like to circling back to the sanctions I
think that this was an important
economic step to put a little bit of a
bite on North Korea to let them know and
it was also an opportunity for coalition
building with other countries to support
the u.s. in this regard so and it
protects United States so people won't
say that the president acted with
impulsivity or recklessness that he
sought some consensus that he tried to
go through the normal diplomatic you
know means by putting in the sanctions
trying to have talks until we have
exhausted all reasonable measures and
then are either forced to defend
ourselves or an ally a couple of things
stand out for me number one is the
president's getting very good at letting
other people convey his policy so if
Matt Lauer doesn't really think he
should be President or says what is this
businessman know well you're gonna say
that to HR McMaster an active General if
you don't like our to but our diplomatic
approach well ambassador Haley's right
in front of your willing to defend it if
you're not happy with the way the
sanctions are being put out what does
president Trump know here's Steve
minuchin to say this is exactly what
we're doing
so he's orchestrating putting people out
there if he's doing when it comes to
taxes of course you got a great OMB
director I think who knows this stuff
backwards and forwards the other thing I
think is important is the president's
doing something that's hard he's putting
in a lot of time how long did he talk to
the Chinese leader close to an hour how
many times they talked to obey of Japan
over and over he's the most active
person now moon is the South Korean
leader and he's liberal and everyone
said wait a second they're not going to
get along and he sat down here today and
says I've really gotten to know
President Trump I don't have the
translation I'll give you the repair
phrase because we've talked so much so
often and next thing you know he put in
the time and he's getting some results a
lot of times you would think a new
politician who's used to instant
gratification who's CEO of his own
company with his name on his building
why don't we have to call this guy again
I just spoke to him he's doing it it's
interesting just because the president
rum hasn't been in New York this many
days in a row since before the
inauguration
it is a lot of time most presidents kind
of complain you didn't hear any of that
even behind the scenes and so it seems
to me it was time well spent because
President Trump is going to need to pick
up the phone and call these leaders and
I think that they having that personal
relationship the one-on-one especially
with him means a lot
maybe moon can tell them what dotard
means right that's north or south you
could help the president has always been
criticized for being this cowboy that
doesn't understand politics yet I think
in the first seven months of this
administration he's really established
strong diplomatic and personal
relationships with a lot of these world
leaders not just our Asian partners too
but in Europe McCrone over in in Paris
and you have Mei who he was just
speaking to President Obama really
wasn't a people person on the world
stage I don't remember one leader that
even comes to mind who I could say no
president Obama really formed a bond
with this guy my favorite cocktail party
questions yeah and his best friend on
Thursday
crickets but it looks like the president
because her background in in business
has really been able to you know for me
I don't think I just don't say there's a
different view I think available and it
comes not only from liberals but
conservatives of what's been going on
here because if you look at what the
Chinese said in response to what the
president has done they said his
language so far not helpful the Russian
said this is engaging in military
hysterics right and they don't see this
as promoting South Korea South Korea
continues to offer humanitarian aid
millions of dollars to the North Koreans
again that would seem in defiance of
what President Trump is talking about
which is cut them off the president
though Iceland has twice big victories
in terms of the unanimous decision on an
embargo coming out of the UN Security
Council awsome about a billion dollars
out of their economy those sanctions
they could but what Rex Tillerson
I think that the North Koreans have
shown a tremendous history of powerfully
evading sanctions making them worthless
but Tillerson said today he thinks there
was already a fuel shortage taking place
in North Korea and he thinks you're
starting to see some impact but the
bottom line to me is when you get
involved in the name-calling when you
start to call people names and they're
calling you names it sounds like you're
giving up the moral superior point right
and I think for a lot of people now
they're saying well you know what guess
what I think that the President of the
United States saying I'm gonna totally
destroy your country is going to be
played over and over and over again on
North Korean TV but you know the press
you know in an interview President Obama
said the same thing in wine your points
are good except for this he has tried
everything I mean do you remember like
about a month and a half ago he came out
and said you know I respect this thirty
five-year-old let's not be easy to take
over a country with all these elderly
der's with a lot of people trying to
kill you it wasn't like oh you crazy why
are you giving him different yeah he
tried that for a while more rockets and
he goes I'm gonna try something else
yeah rocket man okay Brian has fire in
theory somehow strategically deterred
this man answer no I would see all of
these brutal sanctions that are being
levied on North Korea especially this
new Chinese Bank action as major
progress in deterring their and perhaps
it could have a different effect maybe
he will actually act and maybe we'd find
out he was irrational but Kim I wanted
to ask you one last thing that so
throughout this entire week we're
talking all foreign policy and we're
talking complete diplomacy Brian's right
the president is utilizing his cabinet
and his people to go out and talk on his
behalf but you think who wasn't here the
military right even though I don't I
think that there's complete coordination
what the administration was showing this
week visibly for all to see was an
absolute diplomatic push there were
interesting no military angles you know
they used to wear you know Maddox used
to wear a uniform and McMaster used to
wear a uniform I thought that the you
know employing the whole like rocket man
term was enough they didn't need to
bring mad dog mix to just stir it up so
they had HR McMaster yeah you're
absolutely right I think that was a good
point I think it was strategic and I'm
sure that it was purposeful I don't know
it said I didn't notice really I don't I
don't know if they I don't know if it
was purposeful I just think it was to me
striking and if it wasn't purposeful it
was brilliant
players and put them out there to say
this is his area this is his area of
expertise and it's like utilizing you
know you're like starting five to make
sure and I don't know I like I think it
was good but if they totally destroy I
think people think allegation if you do
want to spend I think I've never heard
such language from the process totally
facing a country like North Korea that
actually now has a road pick anything
down and Trump is upset about dotar
because he's like that's not a good
yeah